patients hospitalisés en réanimation
sont âgés de moins de 60 ans 61% monte
entre 60 et 80 ans mais nous notons
aussi que 108 personnes hospitalisées
sont des jeunes de moins de 30 ans est
actuellement en réanimation au cours des
dernières 24 heures 480 de nouveaux
patients ont dû être admis en
réanimation c'est encore considérable le
solde qui représente la différence entre
les personnes entre et les personnes
sorties et donc le nombre total de
patients à prendre en charge en plus
reste un solde positif
dix-sept patients ce soit en plus par
rapport à hier
cela correspond aux besoins
supplémentaires de place dans les
réanimations qui sont déjà quasiment à
leur maximum je vous rappelle que nous
avons doublé nos capacités nationales de
réanimation c'est un indicateur
important qui permet de percevoir
l'extrême tension dans les
établissements de santé
ce besoin de trouver de nouvelles places
augmentent de moins en moins rapidement
59 places supplémentaires hier 94,1 10
140 dimanche 176 samedi mais cette
tension reste toujours particulièrement
forte dans les outre mer guadeloupe
guyane réunion martinique mayotte 145
personnes sont hospitalisées commis hier
et 44 en réanimation
enfin et c'est important 21250 quatre
personnes sont sortis guéris de
l'hôpital ce chiffre continue
d'augmenter jour après jour et bien
entendu il faut y ajouter les dizaines
de milliers de personnes guéries à la
maison et qui n'ont pas eu besoin fort
heureusement d'être hospitalisé la
surveillance syndromique en population
nous montre la fréquentation des
services d'urgence 2706 passage hier
soit 13 % de l'activité totale avec
après un passage un passage aux urgences
41% d'hospitalisation et 3% d'admission
directe en réanimation
l'activité de sos médecins sur le
territoire national est en baisse pour
le coc vide 784 intervention contre 925
pour la journée de lundi
c'est 15% de l'activité totale de sos
médecins est donc en baisse en ce qui
concerne la situation dans les
établissements sociaux et médico sociaux
en raison d'un problème technique qui
empêche momentanément l'accès à
l'application qui recueille des données
transmises par les établissements santé
publique france qui est en charge du
recueil n'est pas en mesure de nous
fournir aujourd'hui un bilan actualisé
de ces données qui concerne comme vous
le savez les ehpad et les établissements
médico sociaux
le bilan des décès reprend donc ce soir
la mortalité hospitalière 7630 deux
décès sont à déplorer depuis le 1er mars
82 % des décès observés surviennent chez
des personnes de plus de 70 ans
nous avons 16 décès en outre mer 10 en
guadeloupe 4 en martinique de à mayotte
au cours des dernières 24 heures c'est
donc un total de 540 et un décès qui a
été enregistré en milieu hospitalier
concernant les établissements sociaux et
médico sociaux et en particulier les
ehpad nous déplorions hier 3237 décès
ajoutez donc au bilan hospitalier s'est
dit 1869 décès en france qui sont en
lien avec l'épidémie
mais je vous le rappelle nous n'avons
pas de chiffres actualisés de la
mortalité enregistrée en ehpad ce soir
l'insee ainsi que santé publique france
on donne des informations très précises
sur la mortalité totale celle qui
survient en milieu hospitalier
celle qui survient dans les ehpad et
celle du revient à la maison en ville
à l'échelon national l'excès de
mortalité atteint 31% en semaine 13 et
émerge aussi petit à petit de plus en
plus fortement sur la semaine 14
compte tenu du décalage de la remontée
des données d'état civil avec un excès
de 27% à l'échelon régional
l'excès de mortalité est observée dans
six régions pour les semaines 13 et 14
grant est ile de france bourgogne
franche comté
auvergne rhône-alpes au de france et
centre val de loire à l'échelon
départemental ce sont 33 départements
qui ont un excès de mortalité en semaine
14 et déjà 32 lors de la semaine 13 5
départements présentent un niveau
d'excès exceptionnel le haut rhin paris
la seine saint denis les hauts de seine
et le val d'oise selon santé publique
france qui recense l'ensemble des tests
pratiqués par pcr est confirmé il y
aurait ce soir 80 2000 cas confirmés par
pcr soit 3881 de plus qui hier vous le
constatez la pandémie de kobe 19 est
toujours très active dans notre pays
nous sommes tous confrontés à une
situation exceptionnelle qui s'inscrit
durablement dans le temps après des
semaines d'évolution nous avons atteint
un niveau totalement exceptionnel inédit
de sollicitations hospitalière des cas
confirmés d'admission en réanimation à
un niveau absolument inégalée dans
l'histoire médicale française
l'attention se relâche à peine dans
certains services de réanimation de
certaines régions mais elle devient
encore plus forte dans d'autres régions
et c'est le cas ce soir par exemple en
ile de france
nous devons donc tous être totalement
mobilisée en première ligne vous le
savez nos professionnels de santé les
soignants qui sont au plus près de nos
malades et ont permis de les prendre en
charge au mieux depuis le début de
l'épidémie en deuxième ligne ce qui
permet au premier de tenir la ligne de
front et entre et en troisième ligne
toutes celles et tous ceux qui doivent
respecter le confinement rester à la
maison
cet agir contre le virus selon certaines
études de modélisation une vie et sauver
toutes les 8 minutes en restant chez soi
je réitère bec donc mon propos sauver
des vies éviter des drames humains
rester s'il vous plaît chez vous nous
devons rester totalement mobilisée
redoubler d'efforts pour trouver des
places en réanimation effectuée 6
besoin de nouvelles évacuations je vous
rappelle que 600 malades graves ont déjà
été effectués afin d'assurer lés
meilleures conditions de prise en charge
pour tous les malades
j'ai conscience qu'après 23 jours de
confinement rester éloigné de sa famille
de ses proches ou de son mode de vie
habituel est un sacrifice et pourtant je
vous le demande encore rester confinées
pour garder l'épidémie sous contrôle en
restant chez vous en respectant tous les
gestes barrière la distanciation
physique minimale d'un mètre la
réduction systématique et drastique des
contacts vous êtes nos armes les plus
efficaces contre la propagation du virus
même si vous avez l'impression d'être
passif vous êtes en réalité les acteurs
majeurs de la lutte contre cette
épidémie
tous ensemble nous avons freiné nous
freinons et nous freinerons encore cette
pandémie meurtrière
le ralentissement observé depuis
quelques jours est liée à votre bon
respect du confinement
soyons donc fort et patients hier vous
avez interrogé sur des signes cutanés
récemment rapporté comme possiblement
associé au coc u19
il s'agissait principalement de lésions
à type d'engelures les plus rapides plus
rarement d'érythème ou de rougeur du
visage avant de conclure à une possible
association avec la maladie kobe de 19
et potentiellement à une conduite à
tenir
la société française de dermatologie
organise actuellement le recensement et
la documentation précise de ces cas
observés en france en lien étroit avec
les médecins généralistes
à ce jour nous n'avons pas encore de
preuves pour affirmer qu'il s'agit d'un
signe planer ducobu 19 mai vous le savez
nous nous apprenons chaque jour sur ce
virus est sur cette maladie
nous restons tous les jours à l'écouté
des professionnels de santé qui nous
contacter et nous leur permettons aussi
de trouver des informations actualisées
ainsi je tiens à leur signaler qu'un
nouvel espace de communication
dédié leur est réservé pour tous les
professionnels de santé sur le site du
ministère de la santé ilir groupe avec
pédagogie toutes les doctrines et les
pratiques à adopter
c'est un canal de communication
indispensable très important et donc
j'invite les professionnels à le visiter
au plus vite et régulièrement afin que
nous menons ensemble un combat
coordonnée et efficace face à l'épidémie
ce soir je rends hommage aux soignants
qui se battent depuis des semaines heure
après heure malade après malades et pour
qui nous devons absolument tout faire
pour alléger leur quotidien et réduire
tous ensemble le poids inégalé de cette
épidémie sans précédent je vous remercie
une question pour ses news allez vous
reprendre les transferts de malades
d'île de france vers les autres régions
donc par tgv ou armée de l'air alors je
c'est une question est importante
puisque nous sommes très attentifs à la
pression actuellement exercées sur les
réanimations d'île de france
l' agence régionale de santé est en lien
avec le centre de crise pour évaluer les
besoins éventuels en évacuation si nous
devons en faire nous en ferons et nous
en ferons rapidement et je tiens à
rappeler aux français que nous avons
réussi cette période difficile à évacuer
plus de 600 patients par toutes les
voies possibles par voie routière par le
tgv médicalisé par hélicoptère par voie
aérienne civile et militaire vers
d'autres régions vers des pays
frontaliers et que ces 600 évacuations
sont aussi d évacuation sans précédent
de malades graves de malades lourds de
malades de réanimation qui se sont
parfaitement passé bien déroulé grâce à
une mobilisation sans précédent de
l'ensemble des équipes soignantes et en
particulier des équipes qui ont assuré
le transfert
plusieurs questions pour la paix m
avez-vous le chiffre précis des décès en
ehpad parmi ceux en établissements
médico sociaux
alors malheureusement comme je vous
l'indiquais je n'ai pas les chiffres ce
soir mais effectivement je pourrais vous
donner la répartition entre les ehpad
les établissements médico-sociaux ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que l'immense
majorité des décès survient en ehpad
versus les établissements médico-sociaux
qui comme vous savez peuvent accueillir
d'autres types de population
quand comment seront les tests en ait
pas de toucher alors il ya déjà des
tests depuis le début dans les états
touchés notamment vous le savez nous
n'avons donné l'instruction que tout
début de foyers suspects en ehpad donne
lieu à une investigation est donc en
particulier il y avait des instructions
depuis longtemps pour que un foyer i am
foyer débutant dans une ehpad puisse
donner lieu à une investigation
épidémiologique et surtout à des tests à
la recherche d'une coronavirus
confirmez-vous que des laboratoires
d'analysés biologiques commercialise des
tests sérologiques sans validation
qualitative officielle et non
remboursables et si oui les autorités
sanitaires compte elle y mettre un terme
ou régulariser cette pratique alors nous
allons bien entendu procéder comme à
chaque arrivée de nouveaux tests à la
validation de ces tests et se trouve que
ce sont forcément des nouveaux tests
puisque les sérologies sont en cours de
réalisation et de validation et c'est
donc bien normal
il ya un gros travail actuellement
effectués par l' agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament par le ministère
de la santé par le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation pour qualifier ces
tests en termes de fiabilité en termes
de sensibilité en termes de spécificités
en termes de faisabilité il y a un lien
très étroit aussi avec le centre
national de référence de ce virus corps
d'un virus et donc nous aurons très
rapidement une liste des tests homologué
par les autorités sanitaires homologué
par le centre national de référence et
les laboratoires bien sûr s'en
empareront et ensuite nous pourrons les
mettre à disposition des français
question de rtl puis joueurs en ce qui
concerne les tests combien ont été
pratiquées ces deux derniers jours sur
des résidents et du personnel soignant
d'ehpad
alors je n'ai pas ce chiffre pour la
simple raison qu'aujourd'hui tous les
prélèvements qui sont faits en ville
dans différentes circonstances arrive
dans différents laboratoires et vous
savez que les ministres de la santé a
élargi l'accès aux laboratoires
puisqu'aujourd'hui pour faciliter cette
croissance du nombre de tests et j'en
parle bien les tests pcr virologique un
de recherche du virus
on a ouvert l'accès à d'autres
plateformes des laboratoires de
recherche des laboratoires
départementaux à des laboratoires
vétérinaires qui ont l'équipement à des
laboratoires de la police ou de la
gendarmerie donc qui viennent en soutien
à toute l'organisation actuelle des
laboratoires hospitaliers de
laboratoires de
il donc énormément de laboratoire sont
mobilisés les prélèvements peuvent être
fait de façon très large sur l'ensemble
du territoire et donc nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui d'informations du lieu où a
été réalisée de prélèvements mais si
nous avons cette information bien sûr
nous la partageons y at il un objectif
chiffré de tests en ehpad
non il n'y a pas d'objectif chiffré de
tests en ehpad je pense que l'objectif
principal du ministre il était très
clair c'est que lorsqu'il ya une
suspicion de cas dans un ehpad l'ehpad
puisse avoir une réponse rapide au
niveau territorial de savoir à qui
s'adresser savoir quel hôpital et
l'hôpital référent et savoir comment
procéder pour avoir rapidement accès à
ces tests
à quelle fréquence les soignants de
rentiers se soumettre au test
alors ça c'est une question qui reste à
trancher la première question est de
savoir si tous les soignants et ça c'est
important
peuvent avoir accès aux tests lorsqu'ils
se sentent malades et c'est évidemment
une priorité puisque vous savez que les
soignants font partie des populations
prioritaires
ensuite il y aura une deuxième question
qui sera celle du test sérologique des
soignants pour que les soignants qui
vont avoir à lutter pendant encore des
semaines pour prendre en charge les
malades sache s'ils sont séropositives
c'est à dire qu'ils ont rencontré le
virus et qui sont immunisés hausse ils
sont séronégatifs et qu'ils doivent être
encore plus attentif justement pour se
protéger et éviter d'être contaminé
question pour le figaro il y a quelques
jours certaines ars n'avait toujours pas
clairement donné de consignes strictes
de confinement dans tous les ehpad est
ce le cas aujourd'hui
est ce que dans chaque est pas les
interactions sont aujourd'hui limitées
au strict minimum
oui vous savez que c'est un c'est un
sujet compliqué qui a fait l'objet d'une
saisine du comité consultatif national
d'éthique pour la simple raison que
confiné des résidents dans des chambres
peut parfois entraîner des effets
secondaires graves pour des personnes
qui ont besoin de contacts qu'un besoin
de soutien qui ont besoin d'un aidant
pour les faire marcher qu'un besoin d'un
proche pour les faire manger est donc
cette réflexion elle a certes été
fortement incité les autorités ont dit
qu'il valait mieux confinée en chambre
mais elle reste à la main non pas
tellement de l' agence régionale de
santé mais bien du directeur de
l'établissement de l'équipe parce qu'on
sait bien que pour certaines pers pour
certaines personnes âgées
le confinement peut être vraiment
délétère et donc on avait laissé à
l'appréciation de certaines équipes de
certains directeurs
la possibilité ou non de mettre
justement ces résidents dans un
confinement plus strictes parce que
parfois et c'est important d'en tenir
compte
au niveau d'un individu le confinement
peut être extrêmement difficile à
supporter la doctrine c'était des pistes
et trois résidents maximum est-ce que ça
a déjà évolué alors ça c'est le ce sont
les propos du ministre des solidarités
de la santé olivier ferrand pour vous
expliquer quelle est la situation
actuelle
actuellement et je voulais montrer dans
le bilan que j'avais détaillé hier il y
a encore une majorité d pad qui n'ont
pas de cas et donc c'est que c est parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de cas doit vraiment
renforcer au maximum leur protection
s'assurer que les résidents sont bien
confiné et s'assurer que les
professionnels qui interviennent ne sont
pas malades seul objectif du ministre et
a été très clairs s'il ya une suspicion
de cas chez un résident ou chez un
professionnel
il doit y avoir une investigation très
rapide pour soi mettre le professionnel
de côté confiné à domicile et éviter
qu'ils contaminent l'ehpad soit géré le
l'isolément dans les meilleures
conditions du résident c'est ce que l'on
souhaite c'est à dire que chaque ehpad
puisse avoir une réaction rapide
une connaissance du circuit de
signalement du circuit de prélèvements à
l'échelon territorial pour être aidé et
soutenu par une équipe hospitalière mais
surtout connaître la démarche pratique
pour avoir accès aux tests
une question pour cnn pourrait vous
faire un point sur la question de
l'immunité collective
comment aborder le déconfinement si le
taux d'infection de la population reste
faible aux alentours de 10 15% comme
semblent l'indiquer les premières études
vaste question et vastes questions
internationales
personne n'a la solution même la chine
se pose cette question puisque vous le
savez en chine
la situation a été très hétérogène la
ville de one a été très touché la
province du hubei a été aussi touché et
puis d'autres secteurs entiers du
territoire chinois ont été beaucoup
moins touchés donc cette notion
d'immunité collectif d'abord aller on
peut être théorique dans le sens où on a
l'expérience des autres virus ne sont
pas forcément les mêmes et on sait on
l'a observé pour d'autres virus
pour que ce virus arrêtes ta circulation
il faut qu'ils se retrouvent confrontés
à une partie importante d'individus
protégé est tout simplement les français
peuvent parfaitement le comprendre quand
on se retrouve infecté et que la
personne en face de vous et immuniser ou
que là de la troisième personne que vous
croisez est aussi immuniser la
possibilité du virus de se transmettre
ces fonds c'est tout simplement ça
l'immunité collectif c'est la difficulté
de la transmission d'un virus d'une
personne à l'autre parce que beaucoup de
personnes sont déjà immunisées soit
naturellement et c'est le cas notamment
de certaines maladies que pour
lesquelles en six minutes tout seul soit
par l'immunité vaccinale et c'est pour
ça que nous on a beaucoup insisté en
france pour la vaccination obligatoire
du nourrisson pour que les nourrissons
qui sont en collectivité soit immunisée
collectivement et qu'il n'y ait plus de
circulation par exemple de la rougeole
donc on a peu d'informations sur
l'immunité collective du coronavirus
puisque c'est un nouveau virus mais
effectivement tous les pays se pose
cette question du niveau d'immunité
qu'il va falloir atteindre ou pas en
fonction de de la stratégie de
déconfinement mais aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes pas là vous voyez qu encore la
vague épidémique continuent de
progresser en france donc c'est une
réflexion internationale c'est une
réflexion scientifique mais lors dudit
confinement n'est pas venu une question
pour vl médias pouvez vous préciser le
parcours de suivis effectués sur les
personnes infectées soigné et guéri qui
rentrent à leur domicile modalités
fréquence de contact durée du suivi
alors c'est une question très complexe
puisque les parcours sont tous
individuel vous avez fort heureusement
l'essentiel des malades qui reste à la
maison et qui en quelques jours guérisse
surtout quand les signes disparaissent
il peut guérir mais peuvent garder peut
être un peu de tout une toux sèche mais
n'ont plus de fièvre et non plus de
douleur ils n'ont plus de mode de maux
de tête et donc ils sont guéris et il
n'y a vraiment aucune inquiétude à avoir
pour eux il ya une situation un peu
moins fréquentes qui est que chez
certaines personnes essaient bien de le
savoir en fin de première semaine on
peut rapidement s'aggraver avoir des
difficultés à respirer et là c'est une
indication et vous le savez c'est dans
les spots que nous diffusons c'est une
indication à appeler immédiatement le 15
le samu parce qu'on a du mal à respirer
on se sent en difficulté lorsqu'on fait
un effort il faut vraiment appeler
rapidement le 15
et puis il ya des personnes fragiles
très fragile malade chronique qui ont
besoin d'une hospitalisation rapidement
parce que vraiment leur état l'indic est
donc cette hospitalisation peut se faire
en médecine elle peut se faire en
réanimation parce qu'ils ont besoin
d'assistance respiratoire et ensuite le
devenir d'un patient de réanimation peut
être une sortie relativement rapide
parce que la réanimation et courtes ou
peut être une rééducation une
réadaptation longue parce que la
réanimation a été particulièrement
lourde et qu'il faut réapprendre à
marcher réapprendre à respirer tout seul
avec un kiné et donc le retour à
domicile se fait après ce long séjour
hospitalier de questions pour mehdi site
la première les mesures de confinement
vont elles être plus stricts lors du pic
de l'épidémie
alors le confinement est déjà très
strictes et je tiens à remercier les
françaises et les français qui
globalement le respecte très bien il n'y
a probablement pas de pique je pense que
le terme n'est pas bon on observe deux
pics nulle part on observe un plateau
dans certains pays c'est le cas de
l'italie c'est le cas de l'espagne c'est
je l'espère le cas de la france dans les
prochains jours mais qui est un plateau
à très haut niveau
vous voyez qu'on nous avons un nombre de
cas exceptionnels en milieu hospitalier
comme en réanimation et c'est un plateau
dynamique paix qui est observé c'est à
dire qu'il reste beaucoup de patients
qui arrivent à l'hôpital
le fait que ça ne monte plus est liée au
fait que il ya autant de personnes qui
rentrent à l'hôpital que deux personnes
qui en sortent
mais la charge en soins le nombre de
patients à prendre en charge reste
totalement considérable pour les
professionnels de santé
la russie se dit prête à tester des
vaccins sur les humains dès fin juin
qu'en est il de la france la france est
très impliqué dans la recherche vous
savez que nous avons énormément de
protocoles d'essais thérapeutiques je
crois que nous sommes allés pays au
monde qui a le plus de protocole en
cours et de protocoles déposé deux
protocoles en cours d'instruction donc
merci à nos chercheurs d'être aussi
actif
c'est valable pour les essais
thérapeutiques c'est valable pour les
essais vaccinaux
la seule chose qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que vous mettre au
point un vaccin et vous savez que nous
avons des très bons chercheurs dans ce
domaine il faut d'abord un modèle ou à
dire cellulaire
l animal puis un modèle humain et donc
il ya des étapes indispensables pour
produire un vaccin et c'est long pour
valider le concept pour tester ce vaccin
chez l'animal et chez l'homme et surtout
pour ensuite s'il est confirmé qu'il est
efficace
le produire c'était les dernières
questions merci à vous